an emergency crew prepares to go
underground in an effort to help rescue
a group of trapped miners
the first task will be to check the air
quality and water level
in the flooded mine in xinjiang province
if the level of hydrogen sulfide gas
gets too high it may pose a danger to
the trapped miners
the good news is currently the oxygen
rate in the coal mine is more than 20
percent
however the water level is still rising
now it's rising by half a centimeter
every 30 minutes
in the previous period it was rising by
up to three and a half centimeters
the mine was flooded on saturday night
cutting off power and communications to
dozens of miners
some have since been rescued but most
remain trapped in three different areas
it's not clear what medical condition
they're in
more than 1400 rescuers are working
round the clock to free them
and specialist pumps have been brought
in to drain away the water
but time is against them our officers
and soldiers have been working
continuously transporting more than 1
000 meters of cables
and cooperating with technicians to
install 52 pump pipes
the work is progressing smoothly the
next step is to carry out follow-up
rescue work after the drainage work is
finished
china is the world's largest consumer of
coal and its mining industry has long
been amongst the deadliest in the world
it reported more than a hundred coal
mining accidents last year
what went wrong this time is yet to be
determined
victoria gatenby al jazeera